[Music]
getting stuck in traffic is horrendous
but even worse than that doesn't it too
often feel like we're the ones stuck in
the slowest Lane and maybe I'm just
being paranoid but honestly this seems
to happen so much it almost feels like
the universe is conspiring to make me
perpetually late or something so why is
that are we just being delusional or is
there actually any truth to it the
answer is more surprising than you might
think although you know what's worse
than getting stuck in traffic trying to
get stuck in traffic and failing because
apparently there are just no cars on the
road I've spent my entire day
according to a recent study the average
u.s. commuter spends 54 hours per year
stuck in traffic this adds up to over 5
billion person hours of lost time but
that time we could build more than 200
Burj Khalifa's 600 Empire State
buildings five large hadron colliders
I'm not even one California high-speed
railway huh
anyway you can see why traffic jams and
especially the psychological effects of
them are a worthwhile area of study and
back in 1999 two researchers looked into
this specific phenomenon of mightest so
many of us feel like we spend too much
time stuck in the slowest Lane and what
they found was that even in situations
where there are two lanes going at
roughly the same speed there are
psychological factors that can make us
feel like our one is going slower
firstly drivers typically only check out
what the adjacent lanes are up to when
they themselves aren't moving secondly
because drivers fortunately look
forwards more than backwards car that
they overtake tend to disappear from
view pretty quickly whereas the ones
that overtake them stay in their field
of vision for longer making them more
memorable and lastly they suggested that
our natural human competitiveness makes
being overtaken moorim emotionally
salient shall we say them being the over
taker by the way I hope you'll notice
that I'm in a Tesla anyway from that
they concluded that actually the
phenomenon really is just in our heads
and while their findings may carry a lot
of truth there's also a much more
straightforward explanation that the
author's completely failed to mention
and that's maybe we feel like we're in
the slow lane because we usually are in
the slow lane
so how can that be well to understand
why first we need to understand
something known as selection effects now
selection effects are just another name
for the biases that can occur when the
method that you use to collect your data
or your information in an experiment
leads to a skewed or only partial subset
of results like if an oceanographer
wants to measure the size of all the
fish in a patch of ocean but only uses a
wide gap fishing net to catch their
sample then all the fish that are
smaller than the holes in the net will
pass through and when the oceanographer
then looks back in their net they'll
wrongly conclude that all the fish are
of a certain size or bigger very silly
now of course good researchers are aware
that the instruments they use to collect
their measurements can bias results but
at the same time selection effects can
be surprisingly tricky to spot and
there's an especially slippery type of
them known as observer selection of face
and I wanted to make a video on observer
selection effects because well they kind
of hide in the shadows of our reasoning
and a very counterintuitive so what are
they well just as our incompetent
oceanographer created selection effects
in his data by using two gapi of a net
he could also create them just by being
there maybe all the little fish are
super terrified of boats and so are
never around to be measured maybe the
big ones are super into them the point
is sometimes an observer can create sort
of biases or errors and screw things up
by their mere presence
hence the observer selection effects
name and as you may have guessed these
observer selection effects affect our
traffic situation thingy in a major way
because when we're stuck in a jam it's
easy to forget that we're not just in
traffic we are traffic to understand why
beat Bob poor old Bob stuck in a traffic
jam that consists of these three lanes
now you can't see which car he's in but
if you had to bet which are the three
lanes would you pick obviously you
should pick Lane B as it contains more
cars than the other two and in the same
way whenever we're the ones stuck in
traffic
we're statistically more likely to find
ourselves in whichever lane
contains the most observers and
therefore the most cars and what happens
when you cram lots and lots of cars into
a single Lane
so next time you're all stressed out
from being late to work at least there's
a universal statistical phenomenon you
can blame it on and speaking of the
universe the reason why I'm so obsessed
with these observer selection effects is
because well they can really affect the
way we think about some of these
big-picture questions about the nature
of reality
in fact they can completely mess with
our heads sometimes and even trick us
into thinking the answers to some of
these questions are super obvious even
when there's often very little evidence
to support them now a great example of
this is the fun question of aliens you
know are we alone in the universe or
just one in a cosmos teeming with
intelligence which as you're probably
aware is a topic that tends to attract
people who are easily upset and believe
some deeply weird [ __ ]
all most of the point it's like aliens
as their religion or something but
seeing as you're all reasonable people
I'm gonna assume that you do at least
agree with me that this remains a
partially unanswered question
[Music]
anyway if you're anything like me then
your first instinct when pondering this
is to go something like well we exists
and so intelligence can't be that hard
for the universe to come by especially
if there are trillions of trillions of
planets out there so they've got to be
at least some smart aliens right but the
thing is our intuitions are easily
observe a selection effected and so what
it might feel like our existence is some
kind of conclusive proof that
intelligence is therefore ubiquitous in
reality is actually not that strong of
evidence because well we've only got one
data point the earth to go by and
actually one of the true chances of
intelligent life evolving on any given
planet are really really likely or as
inconceivable as one in a trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion in
both of those cases we have to exist in
order to even consider the question in
the first place and in fact the only
conclusion that we can reasonably draw
about the likelihood of intelligent life
is that it can exist that the number is
a number greater than zero but anything
more than that we can't know until we
find a second data point until we find
conclusive evidence of extraterrestrial
intelligence which I'm sorry internet we
just haven't found yet
similarly consider the whole
cosmological fine-tuning problem if any
of the major physics of the universe
like the strength of gravity or the
charge of an electron or even the number
of spatial dimensions or even just a
tiny bit different
they're not even stars or galaxies would
have been able to form let alone life
like us
it's a seeming miracle out of all the
possible values they could have taken
they all took on exactly the right ones
that we need to exist in fact it all
seems so perfect that to some people
this is cut-and-dry proof that an
intelligent designer must have created
the universe for us and who knows maybe
it was although it's really not a rabbit
hole I want to go down today especially
if this has meant for your video about
traffic anyway what's important is to
remember how observe a selection of
things could mess with how we think
about this problem for example what if a
universe had very different physics to
our own and
therefore was of a type completely
inhospitable to life in that case
there'd be no observers around to
witness it we could in fact be in a
multiverse situation where there's
countless other weird universes each
with different variations of all the
physical constants all doing their
lonely thing without anyone able to
evolve to observe it but either way in
any universe where an observer does
evolve then pretty much by definition
they'll find their universe appearing
fine-tuned for their existence kind of
like ours does with us now of course the
multiverse theory is just one possible
explanation out of many for this
question of fine-tuning and let me be
clear that I don't therefore think it's
some kind of proof against the existence
of God
in fact intelligent design is arguably
just as plausible of an explanation to
the point I'm simply trying to make is
that the appearance of fine tuning in
the universe isn't definitive proof for
God either and yet so many people seem
to claim that it is and I personally
think that observer selection effects
are at least partially to blame for this
extreme level of certainty that so many
people have in that particular
explanation that's right
traffic yes so what should we do next
time we feel like we're stuck in the
slow lane well if it wasn't for the
massively increased risk of accidents I
guess the optimal solution would be for
everyone to keep switching backwards and
forwards until some kind of equilibrium
is reached and flow rate is maximized
across the full width of the motorway
but seeing as that is neither safe nor
remotely feasible I guess we'll just
have to be content for now knowing that
at least we're not being completely
paranoid because thanks to observe a
selection effects we really are most
likely stuck in the slow lane unless of
course the whole world is driving
self-driving cars in which case that
actually would be feasible because they
would be able to handle switching lanes
perfectly against each other they can
all communicate in some kind of like
hive mind brain thing to maximize flow
rate ah be so beautiful thank you so
much for watching folks I hope you
enjoyed this because this was a
fascinating topic for me to research and
if you want to take a deeper dive I
recommend you check out Nick Bostrom's
book anthropic bias which covers much of
the material
I sort of touched on lightly in this
video today so it's a really really deep
dive so check it out also I wrote a
little bit myself on this topic of the
Fermi paradox and aliens so again that
link is below and lastly of course click
that subscribe and the Bell button and
I'll catch you next time